yeah it went welcome to the city of
playing webmaster Falstaff who is that
I'm Tom demchenko feeder yellow 26 11 Oh
max to 649 that's pretty hot okay so
foul stuff they play bringing Italian
Kate but that all the time and then I
always feel like I don't know it well
enough it's my standard setup it I
usually Wow there are cases where you
can play h5 in this position but I don't
know this is one of them
h 5 95 inch for night of seven this is
all stuff i don't have 94 so probably it
does not work usually need 94 for this
to work okay
hm
yeah counseling short not sure about all
this but so we want to be able to take
with the f pawn if I play nine h5m yes I
think I still do it oh wow that's
supposed to work
I get a couple of points in this line
but it g3t gave three words well it's
probably not quite enough not quite
enough
hmm check it's not exactly what I wanted
really not
I have a hard time to understand this
position here to be honest it doesn't
feel quite right wonder what I did it
but so how to figure out if I someone
can play a five without losing the house
it probably isn't that bad but I don't
know if I'm ever going to be able to do
that probably not this is a very direct
way of doing it yeah i don't think i can
sacrifice yes impossible night transfer
to f five here in this position I don't
know how bad it is
this maybe I can really go for h5 myself
like this rook age 8 and h5 it's just me
look all that bad he wants night c43 and
so on but
that takes a long time
so you're going to play b6 it probably
is now I don't know cannot be all that
terrible nice it's not terrible at all
a position looks good I think
and I don't quite see a good plan for
white unless you can somehow sacrifice
on do something extraordinary in the
center so here the question is am I
taking this or not I don't think I do we
can just do this and now if I take III
and take g 4 i'm going to win a pawn I
really do think I'm going to do it let's
win a pawn if he attacks f6 some somehow
i'm going to play rook of a tycoon have
to or something i can play with evade ya
thinks things are looking looking quite
good don't quite see a good good idea
for why do I take is going to play g3
quite clearly so anything better I would
love to play a 5 something something
like that um what whatever do it
actually like this he takes it i go to
page five it's a little bit brutal but
if it works it's really good
maybe it takes on a 5 first I was
thinking night eggs but that it's not
necessarily all that clear yeah I could
g3 but he's got all kinds of stuff that
you find so on a new page 5 is just
going to take home
time warning
g three nights ago I think I screwed it
up it was a very good position ok
[Music]
should keep live okay
check
I can take h5 I screwed this up terribly
I screwed this up jeremy black resigned
he has one of those games where
afterwards so the engine will show you
how you could have won easily problem so
I'll do i will now take g3d first gym
[Music]
not this one it look good some RF five
min ok this is the this is like for
everybody plays and sometimes you should
just do what everybody did would do it's
just a clean pawn up for absolutely
nothing at two points actually it's two
points this is actually what I missed
I'm two pawns up I was thinking okay
this is just a pawn how am I going to
continue its two pawns that's sick you
know ok this is this is unclear which by
now I was irritated too much i think
this is queenie sense I know completely
lost the threat down I would be
interested in checking still quickly h5
is an idea I don't think it is sometimes
you can play like this and sacrifice the
house in fact the computer says I can do
it with Queenie seven there are even
lines like that but I don't think that
would work here because I i eat night
sorry I need 94 as an option here which
is not available but cooney 7 is indeed
playable I've had something like that on
on the channel and I think I think
actually what the engine is giving here
if you give it more time I think it will
actually switch to black I think this is
kind of interesting
okay as we saw what action wasn't wasn't
terrible I mean like what putting in
pretty substantial trouble but I I
simply simply missed them two parts up
and then other line and champ as I lost
the thread completely still a normal
move would be okay I mean this is just
pretty awful okay it would have been
difficult with the time but still ok
guys thanks for watching